Never before in history has there been
so many people on earth as right now,
our numbers have skyrocketed
from 1 billion in 1800 to
2.3 billion in 1943 point
7 billion in 1970 and 7.4 billion in
2016 the world population increased four
fold in the last century.
So what can we expect for the next century
and what does population growth have
been for our future?
Will there be mass migration,
overcrowded slums in mega cities covering
continents, diseases and pollution,
chaos and violence. So for
energy, water, and food,
and the human species focus
to only on sustaining itself.
Will population growth destroy our
way of life or is this prophecy just
ungrounded panic?
Yeah.
In the 1960s population growth reached
an unprecedented rate which led to
apocalyptic prophecies.
The pool would procreate endlessly
and overrun the developed world.
The legend of overpopulation was born
basket turns out high birth rates in the
population explosion. I'm not permanent
features of some cultures or countries,
but rather part of a four step process.
The whole world is going through
the demographic transition.
Most developed countries have already
made the transition while other countries
aren't doing it right. Now, let's
go back to the 18th century.
When the entire world,
including Europe,
was in the first stage of the demographic
transition. By today's standards,
Europe was worse off than a developing
region suffering from poor sanitation,
poor diet, and poor medicine.
A lot of people were born,
but lots of them died just as fast,
so the population hardly.
Group women have between
four and six children,
but only two of them
would reach adult hood.
Then the industrial revolution happened
in the UK and brought the greatest
change in human living conditions.
Since the agricultural revolution,
people went from being
peasants to workers,
manufactures goods were mass
produced and became widely available.
This science has flourished
and advanced transportation,
communication and medicine.
The role of women in society shifted
and created the conditions for their
emancipation.
Slowly,
this economic progress not
only formed a middle class,
but also raise standards of living
and healthcare for the poor working
population.
The second transition stage
started better food supplies,
hygiene and medicine. Men. People
stopped dying all the time,
especially so at a very young age,
the result was a population explosion
doubling the uks population between 1750
and 1850 the main reason the founders
used to have lots of children was that
only a few of them were likely to survive.
Now that had changed,
so the third stage of the
transition was set in motion.
Fewer babies were conceived and
population growth slow down.
Eventually a balance emerged,
fewer people were dying and
fewer children were born,
so the death rate and
birth rate became stable.
Britain had reached the fourth
stage of the demographic transition.
This didn't only happen in the UK.
More and more countries went
through the four stages. First,
many births and many deaths due
to bad living conditions. Second,
better living conditions leading to
fewer deaths and a population explosion.
Third fewer deaths resulting in fewer
births and population growth came to an
end.
But if birth rates have dropped so much,
why is the population is
still growing so fast? Well,
the children born in the
population explosion of the
seventies and eighties now
having kids themselves now leading to a
noticeable spike in overall population,
but they are having far fewer children
on average than their parents.
The average today is 2.5
it was five 40 years ago.
So as this generation gets older
and fertility declines further,
the rate of population
growth will keep on slowing.
This is true for every
country in the west.
We tend to overlook progress
in other regions of the world,
but actually most of the world's countries
have made it to the fourth stage.
Just look at Bangladesh.
In 1971 the average woman had seven kids,
but 25% of them would die before the age
of five and 2015 the mortality rate was
down to 3.8% and women had
only 2.2 kids on average.
This is the rule, not an exception. We're
not special. We just had a headstart.
It took developed countries about 80
years to reduce fertility from more than
six children to less than three
others are catching up. Forest,
Malaysia and South Africa
did it in only 34 years.
Bangladesh took just 20.
Iran managed it in 10 years.
All these countries that are catching
up didn't have to start from scratch.
And the more support they get,
the faster they catch up.
This is why programs that help lower
child mortality or help poor nations
develop, uh, so important no
matter what your motivation is,
whether you dream of a world where all
people live in freedom and wealth or you
just want fewer refugees
coming to your country.
The simple truth is that it's
beneficial to you personally.
If people on the other side of the globe
can live a good life and we are getting
there,
the percentage of people living in
extreme poverty has never been as low as
today.
So the future of global population
growth is actually not an apocalyptic
prophecy at all. It's a promise
population growth will come to an ENT.
The UN forecast that the 12000000000th
human will never be born at all.
And as the development
level of the world rises,
the number of people with a higher
education will increase tenfold.
Countries who used to be a need.
We'll help advance development in stat.
More people is going to mean more
people able to advance our species.
This video was a collaboration with
Max Rosa and our world in data we're,
he explores the progress of humanity
through research and data visualization.
Make sure to check it out.
In 2016 we were able to make more and
better content than ever before because of
your support on picture on.com thank you
so much and we'll be back in the year
12,017.